buen día pues desde ayer a la una de la
tarde se suspendieron todas las labores
no esenciales en quintana roo y a las 5
de la tarde también las esenciales de
excepto las de salud y seguridad 35 mil
turistas en quintana roo fueron puestas
a resguardo en todos los puntos
turísticos cancún isla mujeres con su
medio la isla de holbox fue totalmente
evacuada cuatro mil personas fueron
llevadas a los albergues también el
centro de convenciones de la ciudad de
cancún se habilitó como refugio para
todas las personas que habitan en la
zona hotelera y que consideran que sus
domicilios no son seguros también se
desplegaron 5.000 elementos tanto del
ejército como de la marina-armada de
méxico y la guardia nacional para
brindar apoyo a la población que lo
requiera se cerraron como ya lo
mencionaba los aeropuertos y por
supuesto también los cruces marítimos
los ferrys entre la isla de cozumel y de
isla mujeres con cancún y con playa del
carmen también en el yucatán se tomaron
las previsiones medida estaba dispuesta
para
y nueve mil turistas de quintana roo que
no hubieran conseguido lugar allá y
también por supuesto los pobladores de
las zonas costeras de yucatán fueron
llevados a resguardo algunos refugios en
san felipe en el río lagartos y en el
cuy o en los hospitales también las
áreas cobit por ejemplo del hospital
jesús combate que estaba pues instalada
con carpas en la parte exterior todos
los pacientes fueron llevados al
interior del edificio para tomar las
precauciones si vivieron algunas compras
de pánico desde la tarde de las personas
que fueron a conseguir víveres para pues
tomar sus precauciones esto entre otras
medidas a la mar yo nos quedan 40
segunditos con qué fuerza e impacto
tierra delta y hacia dónde se dirige
bien pues desde las 530 tocó tierra como
ya lo mencionaba con fuertes vientos que
van sostenidos de 175 kilómetros y
rachas de hasta 205 kilómetros por hora
ya había algunas palmeras derribadas en
cancún se sienten ya los efectos de este
huracán 2 se dirige hacia cancún en las
próximas horas en el transcurso de la
mañana serán los momentos más difíciles
también en yucatán y se prevé que hacia
después del mediodía avance ya hacia el
golfo de méxico pues transcurso el
desplazamiento es a una buena velocidad
por lo que no se prevé que dure mucho
tiempo sobre tierra mexicana